all right sarah and dakota sarah dakota
where are you guys from originally sarah
you're from where
memphis city memphis
in dakota you grew up where
oklahoma
how would you describe your childhood
sarah
pretty good for the most part
uh my parents were always together but
my dad struggled with drugs
and
um
when i was a four or five no five or six
my grandfather like molested me
which drove my dad into drugs which
yeah
it was rocky a little bit my mom was an
amazing person and she like kept
everything together it's pretty cool
you finished high school
uh
technically no i made it all the way to
senior year and then i turned 18
and dropped out and then went to summer
school
and then i moved away to oklahoma and
quit and then when i came back to
memphis i or
he helped me get my ged and i got my ged
dakota helped you yes well he pushed me
to get it got it
what kind of kid were you
like in your high school years as a
teenager
uh very shy withdrawn
bookworm teacher's pet
really good at like
science
uh reading and all that good stuff
sucked at math
but it was a very quiet kid good kid
kept my head down in dakota what was
your childhood like
my mom had me when she was 15
and she originally didn't want me and
try to have an abortion
and when that didn't work
she gave me for adoption when i was 11
years old
and my step-grandmother and grandfather
who my grandfather he was a
truck driver and rode motorcycles and
stuff his whole life was kind of a manly
man and all he had was daughters and
never got to raise a son
and so he took the opportunity to raise
his son and him and my grandmother
adopted me
and
they were broken poor for the most part
we kind of came up for different me and
her on different spectrums
and you grew up wealthy there
uh upper middle class my dad was a a
pretty good airplane mechanic at fedex
for a while until his downfall and he
got kicked out because he filled a drug
test oh i see
so dakota you graduated high school no
no no uh
actually it was me my grandma grandma
and grandfather and my grandfather got
cancer when i was younger and passed
away when i was 14
and so it was me and my grandma and i
started working part-time
and so i was going to school like three
or four days a week and working the rest
and i just i was working for 20 an hour
building fence on a farm and you know
off the table and everything
and i just got to thinking as a young
guy that if i worked you know five or
six days a week and didn't go to school
that i'd make a lot more money and so i
quit school in eighth grade and started
working full time
how was how was your childhood with your
grandparents
uh it was good it wasn't bad my
environment was the most loving person
in the world
our entire town called her grandma and
she
she basically raised every child that
she came across or tried to that's great
she was a loving person and my
grandfather he was just like i said a
man's man didn't nearly take anything or
you know he didn't back talk to him or
anything like that but i wasn't really
beaten or anything like that
i just knew not to you know not to get
loud or not to say anything wrong or
just be respectful basically he was you
know a former marine truck driver biker
just kind of a no-nonsense guy that you
just showed respect to
and you and sarah met how
off uh
at the time it was my yearbook as an
online site and it was intended for like
people to stay in contact after they
quit school
and we just started i uh i was in
oklahoma and i got back in contact when
i uh at 17 with my real mother and then
moved to west memphis to move in with
her to try to have a relationship with
her and then i met her when i was uh
just online talking to girls
you guys have been together how long 12
years 12 years
it's almost like you're married yeah
pretty much
we said we weren't supposed to get
married
so we've been uh together 12 years been
living together at least 11.
no kids
no no kids
and how old are you guys
i'm 29 i'm
30. so you guys have an interesting
aspect to your relationship
most will say yes
how did this come about
it's called uh cockholding
tell me how that came about was your
relationship always this way or did it
not always it didn't start out that way
but it developed that way
how did that come about
well uh
do you want me to tell you how we
started yeah tell me
you started out as a vanilla
relationship no not at all
we were never vanilla we uh started out
actually in the bdsm i was really into
the bdsm and like uh slavery and sub sub
stuff and all that fun stuff
and so we started out as he was my
master
like we went that like they were that
level
and uh my mom found out
because she looked through my phone
because she was very nosy even though i
was 18 at the time
she was one of those very controlling
moms at the time and she freaked out
because she saw me call on him master
and she's like you can't be together
anymore no no no you're never going to
be together so at 18 i left and moved
into oklahoma where we did that for a
while
and then
we got invited from one of our
one of his master friends
to a big swingers party
and we was a lot of fun so then we just
started doing swinging and then when we
moved back to tennessee
it was just easier to
do the swinging and because there was a
bigger there was a bigger swingers
community here than there was in
oklahoma
so it developed into something different
than
dakota being your master yes uh
slowly we uh stopped those swinging and
then started
doing like threesomes and all that stuff
and then
it turned into
me pretty much telling him i'm sleeping
with whomever i want
and you're just going to sit in the
corner and watch
so you became the master kind of i did i
am and dakota how does that sit with you
i like it i enjoy it you enjoy it
so what does this look like i mean
sarah will bring home men or tell me
what happens
yes she'll bring home guys or
we'll go meet guys at like hotel rooms
or stuff but normally she just brings
them home
yep
i like the comfort of my own home
these are just
random guys you meet
well i have a black only preference so
all of them are black but yes
and they're i've made them on websites
or i've given my number out to people
and random and just invited them over
like a guy through a drive-through
i thought it was cute so i gave him my
number and he showed up that night
and this happens how often
um
i try to do it
at least once or twice a week but work
you know it's really hard you guys are
both working yes we work full-time yeah
but
i do it every opportunity i can when i
get free time twice the past week yeah
twice so far
and dakota you you'll sit in the in the
room and watch
the watch and record and stuff like that
yeah or whatever the guys want me if
they want me to do stuff so what is your
experience of this is it humiliating is
it uh tantalizing is it exciting is it
what is it um
it is humiliating but it's also sexy to
watch a guy basically perform better
than i can it's almost like watching
porn
do you think porn is what kind of led
you into this
not really being a voyeur no not not
really
so i think it went from i was doing like
threesomes and swinging
and to us both realizing that it was
more fun if i was just watching and she
was playing with the guys
and you'll pick up different guys each
time
well i've got my regulars that i like
but yeah i cycle through guys and
sometimes
unless i find a library that i really
really like and then i'll play with him
quite a bit
but you're
more
closely bonded with dakota than these
all these other guys i assume right oh
yes yes
most definitely
you're not gonna leave dakota for
somebody you never
never
i will laugh at them and tell them no
sorry
not gonna happen
it's you're gonna take me and and then
he's gonna be there whether you like it
or not
and you have a sex life that continues
with dakota
no
so you guys don't have sex no
not in the traditional sense no not in
the traditional sense at all
oh really so
dakota do you have sex of any sort with
anyone not anymore not anymore
where do you see this progressing this
is this unusual
unusual relationship i would say
i guess i have become possessive it's
mine he's mine
i control what he does when it comes to
sex and is that your personality to be
so dominant be the boss no it didn't
used to be it's because of him i used to
be very shy and not confident at all
he's given me a lot of confidence over
the years
and she's submissive to the other guys
as well oh yeah i am submissive to my
partnership but dominant to him
it's interesting so dakota you and you
enjoy being
the the sub as they call it yeah
it's quite a bit of fun
it's because my whole life and jobs and
everything i've always been into power
or like the supervisor or something and
it's nice for somebody else to have the
power of me not to have to
worry about everything that's going to
happen and just kind of go with it oh so
outside of your home life you're you're
the boss typically at work yeah yeah we
own our own business so i'm the boss of
our little company
he likes driving a lot more than i do
and but but at home
she's the boss yes
and you used to be the boss right
yeah how is it different now
for you
[Music]
well she controls every at the every
aspect basically now and
has the same control that i had
and i just pretty much asked ask
permission before i really do anything
have you ever had like
interactions with with guys that just
went bad or
are they always pretty much what they're
what you have planned
what do you mean by i mean like you know
does a guy ever have expectations that
like why is there a guy in the room or
anything like that
no
well if i have guys like that we'll uh
i'll normally just have him like sit
outside the door and watch
that way he's still watching and
everything but the guy can be like not
being watched i can't really see but
he's just just outside the door is this
a rousing for you dakota
it is good
because i know they're
more more physically fit or they're
bigger or stuff like that they can
perform better basically i guess
in a physical aspect yeah
so sarah so your all the partners you
bring in the african-american men how do
they compare to
dakota
as a sexual partner
let me answer
yeah you can answer
there's a lot better than i am honestly
like several times bigger
the the black men are much more well
endowed than you are
yeah they're much much better than i am
and it's just a
an aspect of she seems to have more fun
with them
she's louder she seems to enjoy it more
so there's a reason i like doing it in
my bedroom and not in hotel rooms
doing in the comfort of my own home and
not in a hotel room where there's walls
on either side
it's interesting because obviously
dakota has evolved to a point where
your happiness is more important than
his pride
yes
a lot of men won't do that and that's
probably how i would say probably 1.9 of
them won't do that
that's a lot of problems
with the world
men need to be a little bit more humble
and listen to their women
dakota you're you're
you're not feeling i mean there's
humiliation you mentioned that yeah
there's humiliation and
i guess in some aspects it kind of makes
me feel like less of a man sometimes
but in all honesty it's not it doesn't
bother me that bad at all
because it's just it's what she wants
and she's happier once you open your
mind it makes you more of a man actually
you're great you're a great partner to
her she's she's free to do whatever she
wants her happiness is more important to
to you than
your pride yeah and
i get away with a lot of stuff that most
people or guys wouldn't get away with
like buying motorcycles or buying stupid
cars or spending money on stupid
guns and cars and stupid stuff like that
a happy wife
if you make your woman happy you get so
many more things
[Laughter]
and meeting
african-american men is not a problem
for you you just do it online or how do
you do it
mostly online but uh sometimes i do it
in person that's what this whole tattoo
means it's supposed to symbolize i uh
i'm exclusive to black guys it's a queen
of spades
and what it means is that i am only
exclusive to black guys it's pretty much
uh hey i wanna
[ __ ] you i wanna have sex with you come
all you gotta do is come and ask and i
will be more than willing to
so that's with that tattoo yes that's
what the tattoo means really yes i have
it on my chest so everybody can see it
i would almost say that like even if
we're together in public and a guy sees
it it's almost like a permission yeah
it's like everybody's like come come say
hi you've had permission to talk to her
like that
in a way
are you guys thinking of having kids
we've tried having kids uh since
year five of this 12-year relationship
but
over the years of
just not using protection
i'll safely mind you uh i just realized
that i just wouldn't get pregnant and
we've even tried like doing the whole
planning stuff and
having intercourse and stuff like that
when you're ovulating and just never
never happened ever never even had a
scare not a once in our entire 12 years
are you using condoms with all your
partners no no i don't
and you're not worried about getting
pregnant
no i'm not it seems like you're not
going to get we'd like to
i would like to but
i've
just never been able to be okay if it
was one of your other partners rather
than dakota
that's what we've tried to oh you're
that's what you're aiming for yes
it is if i have kids i want it to be
mixed
will you tell the father
uh if i know who the father is
[Laughter]
yeah
i mean i'm just like we're not going to
ask for child support or anything and we
wouldn't want to still be his but yeah
be very open about that as well
i don't want them to have any
responsibilities
it'll still be our kid we wouldn't want
to take anything away from them if they
wanted anything like that that's true
in all fairness
i wouldn't ask for child support though
any of that stuff right
because
in the years we've been together
and with stuff i've done with other
girls i've never had any scares and
never almost got to grow pregnant and
going to the doctor they attributed it
to you know my size and everything
and not being able to perform right or
well
and uh
then with her and the other guys
so it was just because we didn't at
first we didn't know if it was me not
able to you know get her pregnant her
able to get pregnant and then with the
other guys and everything is both of us
i guess
guys we both have problems but that's
okay
we did what we horribly called a
breeding party and did like a gang bang
where you know we checked all the guy
had papers and everything for like you
know tests and everything but the whole
point of it was was to have you know
like six or seven guys come over and all
of them attempt to get her pregnant
increase the chances pretty much
and it never worked i guess if you don't
get pregnant after that you don't really
and we've
the we've done the tests and everything
they all came back that she can get
pregnant so we just we haven't went and
got the more extensive tests
and stuff like that but it costs a lot
all the initial testing all came back
perfect
but
it is what it is
we're happy at this point if it happens
it happens if it doesn't then it doesn't
it's not something we're going to try or
not try for i guess
i would assume that this kind of
relationship requires really great
communication and trust oh yes between
the two of you
you feel closer since this started
the relationship changed
i don't think so then we've all we've
always been
i don't feel any different
from the
first couple years we've been together
until 12 years from now and after you
have an interaction with
some guy you met
who comes by and just
does his business and leaves
you guys will talk about it afterwards
or you'll
yeah
he uh helps clean up
does all that fun stuff uh then we just
pretty much like
it's puppy dog we cuddle watch movies
play games just we're in a really good
mood
yeah shower and go back to hanging out
or whatever's going whatever we got
going on and it's a normal
other than the the
the other sexual partners it's a fairly
normal relationship it sounds like
for the most part yeah
people would think it's weird
that sometimes i'll have him just like
wearing panties and stuff around the
house or
uh
i've gotten lots of people who've been
like you're cheating on him you don't
really love him and all this and it's
just like you just don't understand
you think that's it just people just are
too close-minded yeah
i don't know how many times you don't
really love her or she doesn't really
love you you should leave her blah blah
blah blah blah so you just don't
understand
yeah in the past when i talked to girls
it would always turn to this weird
aspect we're going to save you from her
and show you how a woman should treat
you and all this i'm an abusive horrible
person
you're not interested
you're faithful to sarah yep even though
she's unfaithful to you
yep
my grandmother who's now passed away
used to tell everybody that she's the
only reason i'm still alive because i
was into a bunch of like dealing drugs
hanging out with the wrong people
getting in trouble when i was 16 17 18
and then i met her and i quit drinking
quit smoking quit doing everything
basically and just went straight to be
with her
and then changed my life for the better
to be with her
and uh
you didn't have a license until he got
with me
so sarah's influence on your life has
been um yeah i've had several vehicles
and no license just been doing
everything young and dumb basically
until i got with her and she was like
look we gotta like you get in trouble
with the law and things like that
you had two vehicles that were impounded
and taken in oklahoma because i was
driving with you know no license and
they just impounded the vehicles
are drugs are part of your life
or lives a little bit yeah yeah does
that help with the sexual
appetite um
sometimes
i mostly uh for like the anxiety
depression and stuff like that
and then a lot of weeks yeah
nothing nothing hard
no none of the hearty drugs
because of my childhood or whatever i've
never ever wanted to do anything hard
never even thought about it
i was 12 years old and i found my dad's
crack pipe in the yard one day
and that i don't know it left a lasting
impression that i'd never ever want to
do anything like that
we do we'll do eggs or mdma every once
in a while and i really like shrooms but
that's the hardest we've ever done
sarah do you think there was something
in your
upbringing your childhood that
made this
you know work for you or maybe make you
give you this desire to have all these
multiple partners
and do it you know outside of your
relationship with your with your part
with your main partner
um
i don't think
when it comes to the swinging and stuff
but the more like darker like
the
[Music]
the more uh sadistic and that kind of
bdsm stuff i would attribute to what
happened when i was younger yeah because
i don't know what else like when when i
remember when i was younger i was like
this isn't normal so i guess
that's the only thing that really stands
out to me that could change or sway
my opinions or whatever i can even
imagine it but do you think if the
sexual abuse abuse had not happened that
maybe this
this kind of relationship wouldn't be
existing in your life
maybe
or it wouldn't be to the extreme that it
is now but um
i'm happy with the way it is
you guys are happy and you're happy
you're happy with your relationship oh
very you seem to be yeah
and
dakota do you do you see yourself
becoming more active sexually or do you
long for that or
do you just no longer have an appetite
for it
the desire
i'm not sure honestly because it's
it's still going down basically because
you know because it was a lot and then
it's kind of just gruntled down to not
really anything
and you're still a young man so you
should have a 30 a strong
sex drive yeah
but you have none at all
i do but no it's not to say he doesn't
do anything sexual he just doesn't have
intercourse
i don't allow him to do that
like he's still
like i'll make him edge and do all that
stuff but
other like he just doesn't intercourse
and no other females like i'm very
possessive he's mine
so he's not allowed to have other
partners
not unless i specifically say so when
i'm there but he's made to watch you
have all that kind of partners you want
yes
you feel like that's fair
you know normal relationship probably
not yes in a normal relationship no but
in my relationship yes because it's my
relationship and i'm in charge
and it's what i want to do and dakota is
cool with that also talk to other girls
like text messages and stuff like that
but i don't do anything with them
and this just is fun for me i enjoy it i
like the communication and the talking
and the stuff like that
what do you guys learn from from this
lifestyle that you've
gotten into
do you have any do you have any insights
into relationships and love and
because you guys
you guys seem very committed to each
other oh yeah always be open try new
things talk about stuff like
if something's bothering you or you want
to try something don't be afraid to talk
to your partner about it
if you are afraid to talk to him you
might not should be yeah if you are
afraid to talk to him about it then you
should probably rethink your uh think
your relationship with somebody you
can't talk to about it
do you guys tell each other everything
yes there's no secrets there's nothing
that you're no yeah
if we want to try something we try it
even if it's the most weird thing ever
like that
i remember having a dream when uh we
first got together
about him uh
peeing on me in the shower and i was
like
it turned me onto my dream and it
sounded like a lot of fun so it was like
i felt comfortable enough to go to him
be like hey i want to try this it sounds
like fun
and then we tried it and i realized yeah
i like some aspects of it but others not
so much she's in
and we just learned
and she literally came to me like i had
a dream like this and it seemed kind of
fun you want to try
sure
it was kind of like the the master slave
stuff originally when i first got
together i was kind of into it it seemed
fun but when you have a you know young
woman say you can do whatever you want
to me you can be in sharks like all
right that sounds fun
be like here
is it more fun being the
submissive rather than the the dominant
in the relationship honestly it's the
actions themselves like
where i would explain whether it's
choking somebody or being choked it's
just the aspect of it
like just an added aspect it's not
really me doing it or somebody else
doing it
if that makes sense
like he really likes he really likes sex
like
the aspect of everything whether he's
doing it or he's watching it being done
so it's like here if that makes sense
you're a connoisseur of
pretty much sex it sounds like
and your wife is the
canvas basically
how many partners have you had outside
of this relationship
i mean outside of me and how many guys
have you roughly
brought in
brought into my relationship oh yeah
hmm
i'd say what
two three hundred plus
yeah he's been doing this a really long
time if it's two a week like it depends
if you count
just the cuckold type stuff or if you
count everything we've done over the
years
the two a week was two guys each time
so that would be four this week oh
there's two two guys at a time yeah
yeah multiple i've had
[Music]
sometimes on our anniversary before
covid we would have a gang bangs for our
anniversary and now we'd have
four five six guys in a hotel room or at
the house and he would watch and film
and that was our anniversary gift to
each other it was an eight or nine year
anniversary we had eight or nine guys
like the number of europe we've been
together so many guys came over
and these are all african-american men
yes and you and you're always in the
corner watching yes
it's funny because
at first doing it or soon online you
would think like they're kind of they
look down upon you but they all like act
like i'm cool this year you you're so
cool man you're cool as [ __ ] you're not
like everybody else
most partners who get very jealous
be uneasy with the whole thing
a lot of men do like before the pandemic
we would go to like parties it would be
like swingers but be all white girls and
black guys and then it'd be me and her
and it would be like 30 black guys i'd
just be walking around talking to
everybody and just dreaming cool as [ __ ]
and just how cool it was that we were
there that i brought her there stuff
like that
[Laughter]
what do you think most people that have
vanilla relationships
don't understand about
but what what's out there what they
could
be experiencing
it seems like you guys may maybe have
discovered something
i think people take sex way too serious
yeah religion and uh has made you think
that sex is taboo and bad and it's
really not it's just fun
and when you stop thinking of it as
something to you have to do and just
think of it as fun there's a lot more
you're open to do
and it's not so much about controlling
your partner
as it is about just enjoying your
partner yep and what they enjoy yep
well it's like because i consider myself
a straight guy and i don't look at other
men and think they're you know
attractive or sexy but if a guy comes
over and wants me to do something with
him and her i will like doesn't bother
me to do stuff with guys it used to
bother me quite a bit but it's just fun
it's just sex
it's not like uh
i don't know
and when your dom is telling you to suck
ticky
i'm sorry
say it again please
that's then when you're dominant it
tells you to do something you do it
to another guy
to anybody
so so sometimes dakota is in getting
involved with the other guys
if they're okay with it yeah
we just have to have open minds i guess
right yes pretty much what they're okay
with yeah like i get a mixed bag it's
like 50 50. some guys are okay with it
and some guys aren't
but we just we do whatever so whatever
the guy is comfortable with it was what
we do we try to accommodate him
and i don't really understand it but
some of the guys don't want me to watch
but they're fine with me recording it's
like they're fine with me looking at
them with the phone between us but they
don't want me looking at them without
the phone between us
so me recording makes a lot of the guys
more comfortable because it's something
other than me just being there i guess
instead of me enjoying them being there
it's like i'm recording and stuff all
guys are different and have weird quirks
you realize
and we joke that she gets other guys and
i get motorcycles like i've got two
bikes that's my passion my life is
motorcycles
you guys are both satisfied yep
compromise compromises that's very
important is compromises too you got to
be willing to compromise
or meet halfway
you can't be stubborn
and i don't know if it had a lot to do
with the changing from me being dominant
to her but i had a motorcycle accident
in 2015 and was told there was a great
chance i might never walk again
like i broke my back neck ate ribs
collapsed my left lung broke my
collarbone was sticking out broke my
shoulder my
uh
pelvis
ripped my left thumb off they had to
surgically repair it like the only thing
that kept it attached was the motorcycle
gloves i had on i was escorting a
funeral
and i was standing there with you know
the sirens on the flashers on telling
people to stop and this lady decided she
was going to stop
and
i spent what two weeks in the hospital a
week in the hospital
a little over a week
and this was 2015 and so i was
22 and being told you may never walk
again at 22 was it was terrifying
and
[Music]
i don't know if i'd have made it through
it without her because there for a few
years i was very depressed and couldn't
do anything it was like a year of me you
know not being you know not being in a
walker being able to do stuff and then a
year of me walking in a cane and then a
year of me walking you know normally
until now oh see we lost everything
because of that rifle i moved in with my
parents and everything
it took us a while to get back up but
we did it
that's when a lot of her playing with
guys came in because i physically was
unable to for years and we've always
been so sexual it didn't seem you know
it wasn't her fault to have the accident
and didn't seem fair her not to be able
to do anything or have fun or enjoy
stuff just because i was you know
hurting everything
and i never saw it as oh i'm hurting
you're outgoing you know doing this
stuff it was just seemed fair
but you're fully functional now yeah
yeah
yeah she's the one because they the
doctor told me i'd never be able to ride
a motorcycle again so i wouldn't be able
to hold it up
and three four years three four years
after the wreck she pushed me to get
another bike
because i was moping around the house
one day and she was like look let's go
to the harlow dealership
and i was like why we went down there
and i sat on one just started crying and
then we bought it a week later and it's
just been about another one like six
months later and that one time we had
three bikes and now we just have two yes
yeah
it seems like you guys have a great
relationship yeah because like the the
other girls like said that they'll be
like well we're gonna save you from her
and give you what you deserve i'm like
this someone wiped my ass for years i
couldn't you know physically turn around
i was like you don't get much
much more loving or devoted than that
it seems like it's obvious that you guys
love each other oh yeah but you're just
you're just very open-minded compared to
most people come yeah as they compare to
most people nowadays very yes
all right sarah and dakota thank you so
much for sharing your stories thank you
thank you
for letting us
you